[Music]
welcome back to another episode of real
estate the Ramsey way I'm Dave Ramsey
and today we're talking about a stupid
housing Trend that's getting out of
control the famous HELOC if you're not
familiar you're going to want to keep it
that way but just so we're all on the
same page HELOC stands for a home equity
line of credit which is a type of loan
that allows you to borrow cash against
your home in other words it's just
moving debt from one pile to another
with a lot of risk involved and last
year the number of overall pcks
increased Nationwide along with the
balance of the loans and that's a
reversal of a 10-year Trend that was
going in the right direction so keep
listening to understand why a HELOC is
not the answer to your cash flow
problems Tina's in Fort Lauderdale hi
Tina how are you hi guys I appreciate
your show I'm good thanks um my my
question is around um using a HELOC to
put 20% down on a new home nope and then
selling the current home right after
closing on the new
home oh that home I got confused okay
yeah so you're going to close on you're
going to close on another property
before yours
closes I I would like to so um that's
pretty dangerous I just yeah okay what
happens if done close you got two house
payments and you know what you become
after that we call them a motivated
seller who sells their house cheap CU
they get
stuck three times that happened to me
whoa you didn't learn after the first
one no no no three times I have gone to
closing or within a week of closing the
deal is fallen through oh when I'm
trying to sell a property oh yeah yeah I
see okay and yeah we're going to close
on the second one after the first one
closes mhm then we use cash I just did
that I just did that I I'm in my second
real estate property now um and when I F
sold the first home and to get into this
new home that I live in now um it was
really stressful for me to not have
anywhere to live like in the interim I
happen to just you know what's more
stressful two house payments yeah two
mortgages how how long of a gap are you
talking here um I mean I would
immediately like when I would close I
would put the you know the original home
up for sale I guess my idea of doing it
that way is because you know I um this
closing on this new this
is the sale that I did just now it was
really stressful for me the move I was I
need to find a home where am I going to
live um you know and I would have
preferred to be able to secure a home
for me first um write a contract on the
other on the property you're purchasing
contingent on the sale of yours and set
the closings up on the same
day but if yours doesn't if your current
house doesn't close you don't close on
the new
one because you're going to end up a two
house payments in a market that has
slowed down with higher interest rates
and uh you're going to be calling me two
years from now going I've did the
dumbest thing I got two house payments
that's killing me can you help me
Dave okay and then and aside from that
so what if I could take out a HELOC
enough to pay for a home cash um because
I have quite a bit of well enough equity
um in my current home I listen here's
what Tina you just you you be you okay
you go be you that's what you need to do
don't take out a Helu ever ever period
ever sell your stinking house and move
and quit talking to me about stress
you're trading one kind of stress for
another because you don't perceive the
risk that after 30 years of doing what I
do I've seen people step in it up to
their knees and I'm begging you not to
do that Jake is with us in St Louis Jake
welcome to the Ramsey Show hey Dave hey
Ken how you doing better than we deserve
brother how can we help had a quick
question so I I've been teaching leading
FPU and I just actually just finished
Financial Coach master training and I've
been telling people for years about
helocs and stuff that they've been
that're just a you know credit card
attached to your house exactly um but I
had a quick question we were my wife and
I were walking in our neighborhood and
one of our neighbors told us hey I was
looking to move but housing Market's
crazy and my banker told me I have
$70,000 of equity so he I don't know if
he did a cash out refinancer or whatever
but um was doing instead of buying a new
home he was upgrading his home and I
guess my question is is what is the
difference between doing that as long as
you're doing it to actually upgrade your
home and just buying a new home and
financing all of that stuff already in
the
home well the biggest thing is is these
are repairs or updates you should have
been doing all
along and so they don't come at you at
$70,000 in one bill and if you can do
them $70,000 in one bill you can do them
in phases and you can cash flow them and
then you don't need to add the debt um
obviously you know from Coach master
training that even with a mortgage we're
going to teach you to get out of the
mortgage so we don't want you every time
you want a nicer home to move up in home
or to renovate your home either one we
want you to pay cash for doing either
one of those things because ultimately
we want to end up being 100% debt-free
so I would reframe the approach and say
um instead of let's figuring out a time
that debt is okay let's figure always
figure out a way to avoid
it and just not even ask the question is
my point um so I mean your neighbor
didn't ask you for coaching or me and so
but had they asked me for 70,000 bucks I
I'm going to guess and say he probably
could have cash flowed that in 24 months
or maybe 36 months and done it in three
projects because it's probably not just
one thing and um if it is a $70,000
single Improvement that's highly unusual
highly unusual uh now you could do a
$200,000 addition to a property and that
would not be unusual uh in that case I
just move personally uh in almost every
case and you hear me say that all the
time but even when you move you're
moving into a Better Property you're
going further into debt now you got to
turn around and reverse the process
again and start getting out of debt
again and so I'm always trying to figure
out a way to to to stop the
borrowing not figuring out a way that
it's okay under what conditions is the
borrowing okay instead of going that way
it's always figure out a way to stop the
borrowing cuz see what I did Jake as you
know know is when I went broke I vowed I
never borrow money
again and so this is not an option for
me if I want to upgrade my house I want
to move up in house I want to fix
something at my house there's only one
method I can use because I'm never going
in debt again there only one method I
can use I have to pay cash we're
nowadays we got more zeros on some of
our projects we're building a conference
center on top of the hill here right
above this building uh that's about $40
million
uh we're about halfway through it a
little more than halfway through it um
I'm at about 26 million in right now and
uh we got about a year left so that
tells me I got about two million bucks a
month to cash flow this puppy out the
door and we're watching it cash on cash
cash on cash cash on cash and I'm from
Antioch Tennessee I don't know where you
came from guys but that's a lot of money
to me that still freaks me out you start
talking about $2 million for something
start talking about $2 million a month
for something something that just blows
my little country mind I'll tell you but
that's what God has said we're able to
do we have the money he's showing us to
do it we're doing it and we're going to
help a lot of people with that
conference center and that's a tool and
what we're doing with it it's not
something I'm buying for personal
consumption um so um you know so again
if I want a conference center I got to
rent one I got to use something around
here and stack chairs too high we have
to have cubicles that are two stories or
something in here uh until we can afford
to do a different building a better
building because we just don't borrow
money we just took it you know Anthony
O'Neal used to say it well when he was
here as a Ramsey personal he said you
have to take debt off the
table if you've got a big expense coming
up but don't quite have enough savings
to cover it a HELOC may sound like a
good idea but it's actually one of the
biggest Financial traps you can fall
into to learn more about what exactly a
helck does and what you should do
instead check out the link in the show
notes or go to ramsy solutions.com
selock Michael is in Alaska hey Michael
welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you it's a pleasure to be
talking to you you too what's up hey so
I just got a quick question I got a
little bit of Consumer Debt and I own a
home so I got a little bit of equity um
what are your thoughts on possibly
taking out a a HELOC or equity loan to
pay off that Consumer Debt bring down
the APR and stuff like that and then
just throw that equity loan into my uh
debt
snowball I
wouldn't okay you want to know
why why because you're going to feel
like you did something and you didn't do
anything all you did was move it now
listen all you did was move
interest R not your problem lack of a
budget lack of focus lack of attacking
this is your problem you need to get
fired up and pissed off about being in
debt okay and get after your debt List
It smallest to largest pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one and get after it CU here the problem
when people move debt around they use
words like pay it off you didn't pay it
off you moved
it and 2% savings on the interest rate
is not your issue your issue is getting
focused getting on a budget living on
beans and rice sell so much stuff the
kids think they're next get fired up and
wired up baby that's what does it that's
what moves the needle Ken we there's so
much of what you teach about jobs and
what we teach here that is about
action it's
um
motive which leads to motivation yes
personal finances 80% Behavior avior
it's only 20% head knowledge there's so
much about a job choosing a career
stepping into something that is about um
you know TR don't try to trick it to
don't try to trick your way past the
hard work there's no shortcut to any
place it's worth going Beverly sales
used to say he's absolutely right and so
why are you going after it you've got to
remind yourself on the journey why am I
doing this I get that it takes time you
know if you walked out on the street
today with a camera and a microphone and
you asked people uh are you willing do
whatever it takes to get where you want
to go whether it be career or and your
money most people look at you and
instantly say absolutely but if I
followed up and I said well but I think
they mean that but then here's the
follow-up question if I said are you
willing to wait as long as it takes oh
that's exactly what happens they
literally can respond that way and
here's why that there's something about
The Human Condition where we want
everything now that's what this journey
is all about it's what Dave talks about
all the time it is it is the budget
helps you control the behavior issue or
you go hey this is a long SLO this is
going to take time and so you have to
whether it's in your career and doing
work that you deeply want to do because
you know you were put on this planet to
do it uh or it's paying off debt uh and
saving money so that you can live like
no one else all of this is the same
exact conversation you want to live like
no one else you want to work like no one
else it's going to take time and you
better have the big picture in mind and
know that this is a climb but it is
going to be worth it when I get there
there's no shortcut there is is not a
shortcut a generation ago there was one
of the world's best golfers was a guy
named Gary Player yes and the story's
been told about him over and over and
over again through the years that he was
warming up at a
tournament uh on the driving range and
he's you know pulling back that driver
and sailing that ball out there 300 360
350 yards whatever just popping that
drive straight as a string and this guy
walks up behind him and goes I would
give anything to hit a golf ball like
that m MH and I think I think he caught
him at the wrong moment cuz he turned
around and said no you wouldn't yeah
it's a f fantastic story no you wouldn't
yeah you would not stand out here in the
Heat and hit 2,000 golf balls hit golf
balls so long that you get blisters get
hit golf balls so long that the blisters
bus hit golf balls so long that you
can't hold the golf club anymore from
the busted blisters you tape up your
hands and you hit another thousand balls
you wouldn't do that yeah that's right
you wouldn't do anything to hit a golf
ball like that to which the poor guy
just said I'm sorry I asked you but you
know but just you know that's the thing
you know I I I would do no you wouldn't
you got you got to be willing to do it
and and so that's the thing and I'm not
picking on Michael here that's not the
issue but the issue is there's a thing
about uh action and paying the price
live like no one else so that later you
can live like no one else that
supersedes a little bit of Interest
saved by moving it to a hea so true 88%
of the people that move their debt over
for debt consolidation go further into
debt don't get out of debt yeah nine out
of 10 times yeah it's interesting they
don't change their habits that put them
in there in the first place that's right
they feel like they did something mhm
and that's dangerous to feel like you
did something when you did nothing so
the home equity loan is back yes home
equity line of credit the hilock the
home equity line of credit and Life
Hacker says I used one when I got in
trouble so you should everyone should
have one in this stupid butt article I
remembered we'd taken out a home equity
line of credit when we bought the house
and it saved our butts oh really oh
really his whole house is leveraged on
this money yeah so you know do you know
what a home equity line of credit is
explain it for him Dave it's
debt it's a second
mortgage and you know what they base the
interest rate on your credit nope
whatever they feel like when they wake
up that morning cuz it's variable it's
completely variable and it is not
indexed to any outside thing so Mr
Banker says
today I think I'm going to charge Joe
and sus stupid money so you mean to tell
me in 2021 when I saw everybody in my
neighborhood redo their yard redo their
kitchen redo everything and I'm going
where's this money coming from it's
because they took advantage of their
home equity they leveraged that's the
word I like Dave they leveraged well I'm
I'm sophisticated because my My Equity
otherwise was not working for me and now
I have new
bushes at what cost yeah that's that's
what the you know and that's what the
banking ads sound like don't they I mean
if you listen to if you listen to Sofi
oh yeah it's m SM money moves I'm just
going to Sofi throw up right here oh my
God man I Dave I told you this before
the break it's a good thing cuz I did so
much stupid stuff before I got a hold of
of the prin principles here if I had
known about a HELOC thank God I didn't
know about this cuz I would have just
added it to the list of dumb stuff right
next to co-signing alone yeah I would
have put HELOC yeah well here's the
thing there's a lot of idiot financial
planners and people like life hacker who
will tell you to get a home equity loan
in case there's an emergency now let's
follow this line of in air quotes
logic okay so you lose your job or you
have another Financial Calamity of some
kind so the home equity line is there to
help you you can go draw on it and you
have
money so at the moment that I've lost my
job or had a financial Calamity is
precisely the moment that I want to go
deeper into
debt this is the line of thought that's
a head scratcher yeah so I you know I've
had financial planners talk about this
for years and I've had to just rip their
sh rip them to shreds because it's just
so freaking stupid not all of them do
that but I mean some will say open a
home equity line of credit don't use it
and use the fact that you can go tap
into it if you need to as your emergency
fund and and I always tell them so what
I want what do I want to do when there's
an emergency what I want to do is add to
the anxiety and the stress by going
deeper into debt right you're turning
dumber than a rock oh my God it turns
the emergency into a crisis into a
crisis because now you got whatever it
is that you're having to deal with and
you have to pay off the debt and it's at
a variable rate of Interest so her her
point was is that they had a uh they had
a uh damage storm damage and they were
able to use their home equity loan to
fix it because apparently you don't know
how to work with your insurance company
because if you have storm damage and
your roof's leaking your insurance
company will show up start writing
checks in about 36 minutes
yeah uh if you actually know how to talk
to them instead they didn't show up for
you you know why because you didn't need
them because you went into
debt yeah there's a lot underneath the
surface here on this article and let me
tell you what else happens every time
you do this scrap right here okay house
gets torn up we use debt to fix the
house and we're going to pay off the
debt when the eer when the insurance
check comes you know what you always do
100% of the time people well 98% of the
time people will do more repairs to the
house because while we're at it we're
going to go ahead and renovate then the
insurance check will cover so when the
insurance check comes it's not enough to
cover because we while we were at it we
did some other stuff yeah
and human freaking nature that's what I
love in this article he says the HELOC
allowed us to get started immediately
with repairs as if insurance won't show
up when a roof gets blown off your house
yeah I mean really if you have an
insurance company on homeowners that
will not show up and give you help
immediately when there's storm damage
you have other issues that a HELOC won't
fix you know I wonder what would happen
if you just saved up for emergencies oh
wait you had money money if you just
saved up oh there's an idea I wish I'd
had thought of that and you had the
amount we should we should do a radio
show about that that's awesome idea and
in your 3 to six months you had the
amount of your homeowners insurance
deductible and you didn't have any
payments and so while you're at work
you're making money without any payments
and you have an emergency fund and then
when you have a crisis you have this
thing
called
money that's a great idea Jade and you
just go what is it that sucks all right
write a check yeah that's all you do
Dave emergency fund turns a crisis into
an
inconvenience
and a home equity loan turns a crisis
into an opportunity to be crisis squared
m double up triple up exponentially
worse so here's the here's you're not
sophisticated if you used a home equity
loan to cover your problems in life
you're
broke M and there's nothing
sophisticated about being broke it's
just dumb okay just dumb now I've been
dumb and I've been broke so stop being
dumb stop being broke we're going to
walk you through this and and you don't
use well I I'm I'm you know I'm
utilizing the equity in my home that
otherwise would not be working for me
you're an idiot okay when you say stuff
like that you're just an idiot because
you are you're truncating your most
powerful wealth building tool you're
slowing your wealth building down
because you didn't have any money to
cover emergencies so everyone should
have an emergency fund after they're out
of debt except their home baby step
three of 3 to 6 months of expenses we've
been saying that for 30 we've been
saying that longer than home equity
loans have been in existence they were
not even in existence when we started
this radio show 30 years ago they didn't
make them and now now we have a HELOC
because we a HELOC sounds it sounds so
you're lock I'm a financial person of a
helck you get a helck you get locked
into debt yeah that's about it you know
what I I think somebody ought to
complain why didn't they call it a
shock Dave don't go there I think I
think I just got canceled somewhere in
the
universe any way you look at it a hilock
is still debt meaning you end up paying
for the expensive thing you were trying
to shortcut paying for plus thousands of
dollars extra RA in interest and a ton
of bogus fees and if you default or
misstep in any way the bank could take
your home the truth is hel loocks keep
people broke by making them think
they've solved a problem when all they
did is just move the problem or the debt
around just don't do it it's not the way
to build wealth and it's definitely not
the way to financial peace all right
guys thanks for listening today and make
sure to share this episode with someone
who needs it and don't miss the next one
where we dig into Home Ownership trends
that could cost you thousands of
dollars